[Música]
un abuso de poder atroz así calificó
Donald Trump la acusación en su contra
por el mal manejo de documentos
clasificados encontrados en su
residencia de Florida Si pruebas Trump
reiteró que Joe biden está detrás de su
caso y afirmó que si regresaba a la
presidencia designará a un fiscal para
que judicialice al demócrata
el litio estuvo en el centro de las
conversaciones entre la presidenta de la
comisión europea Úrsula Wonder Legend y
el mandatario argentino Alberto
Fernández Los líderes discutieron la
inversión energética y el acuerdo
comercial entre la Unión Europea y
mercosur
la salud de los cuatro niños indígenas
rescatados en las selvas de Colombia
evolucionó muy satisfactoriamente Ese es
el nuevo parte clínico luego de que los
menores de edad sobrevivieron 40 días
solos en medio del bosque
Bienvenidos a las noticias que France 24
le dedica a América yo soy María Clara
calle
empezamos en Estados Unidos donde el
expresidente Donald Trump reaccionó ante
la acusación en su contra por el caso de
documentos clasificados encontrados en
su residencia de maralago en Florida
ante un grupo de seguidores en Nueva
Jersey Trump calificó como un abuso de
poder atroz la inculpación y arremetió
contra el presidente Joe biden a quien
ha acusado de estar detrás de lo que él
llama una cacería de brujas agregó que
de ganar las elecciones de 2024
designaría a un fiscal especial para
perseguir a biden Trump es acusado de 37
delitos federales escuchemos parte de lo
que dijo Yo soy el que sigue la ley Yo
soy el único
es Joe biden y su corto departamento de
injusticia ellos son los que creen que
está por encima de la ley nunca antes ha
habido dos estándares de justicia en el
país los han relevado de una manera tan
dramática Joe biden tenía montones de
documentos clasificados de su momento
como vicepresidente incluso de su
momento como senador en México la
alcaldesa de Tijuana Monserrat caballero
denunció amenazas contra su vida La
mandataria de esta zona fronteriza con
Estados Unidos decidió por recomendación
de la guardia nacional mudarse a un
cuartel militar por su parte del
presidente mexicano Andrés Manuel López
Obrador aseguró estar al tanto de las
amenazas y confirmó que la mandataria
está protegida desde hace cerca de 15
días según cifras oficiales Baja
California estado al que pertenece
Tijuana es el tercer territorio más
violento de México con 945 homicidios
entre enero y mayo de 2023
o fue una sugerencia de la guardia
nacional Una sugerencia en razón de las
amenazas que recibí amenazas que no sé
de quién de quién vienen o de Qué grupos
o personajes más que tener miedo es la
seguridad que represento porque se cuida
a la alcaldesa que cuida por su parte a
dos millones de ciudadanos en Guatemala
ya comenzó el plan piloto para solicitar
un permiso con el fin de migrar
legalmente a Estados Unidos todo esto
hace parte de la política de Washington
de lo que llama una movilidad segura
nuestro corresponsal Andrés Suárez nos
amplía desde antigua se tiende un puente
de migración legal desde Guatemala hacia
Estados Unidos a partir de esta semana
comenzó el plan piloto con el cual los
nacionales del convenio centroamericano
sea cuatro es decir los ciudadanos de
Guatemala El Salvador Honduras y
Nicaragua podrán solicitar asilo u
obtener una visa para Vivir de manera
legal en Estados Unidos y para ellos ya
está habilitado el portal movilidad
segura punto org quienes Allí se
inscriban deberán calificar a una de las
vías regulares de migración bien sea la
de reunificación Familiar o recordemos
con la reciente implementación de la
política migratoria del título ocho
deberán demostrar un verdadero miedo por
persecución política o judicial o de
violencia que es una realidad muy común
que afecta a estos países
Centroamericanos donde están instalados
gobiernos autocráticos donde se denuncia
que hay acecho judicial donde operan
clandestinamente las pandillas conocidas
como las maras quienes estén inscritos
quienes hayan calificado podrán entonces
agendar una cita presencial en una de
las oficinas de movilidad aquí en
Guatemala exponer su caso aunque esto no
garantiza que les vayan a probar la
migración legal Eso sí hay voces
escépticas como las de los directores de
las oficinas de las casas del migrante
quienes aseguran que se está trasladando
un problema de congestión Migra que
sufren actualmente México y Estados
Unidos en sus fronteras está viniéndose
entonces para Guatemala y se prevé que
estas oficinas de movilidad seguras se
atiborren de migrantes
avanza la gira del presidente de Irán
ebrahim Racing por América Latina el
mandatario llegó Este martes a Nicaragua
donde se reunió con su homólogo
nicaragüense Daniel Ortega Racing
aseguró que en Managua Busca incrementar
y profundizar las relaciones bilaterales
en diferentes áreas como los lazos
políticos económicos y culturales un día
antes el líder iraní estuvo en Venezuela
donde firmó un acuerdo para expandir el
intercambio comercial con Caracas que
espera llegue a más de 20 mil millones
de dólares
otra gira es la de la presidenta de la
comisión europea Úrsula bonder Legends
primero estuvo en Brasil y este martes
visitó Argentina junto con el presidente
de Alberto Fernández firmaron un
memorando centrado en cadenas de valor
de materias primas sostenibles y abordar
un temas como el acuerdo comercial entre
la Unión Europea y mercosur previamente
nos amplió nuestro corresponsal en
Buenos Aires natalio cosoy en la
conferencia de prensa conjunta que
mantuvieron con el presidente Alberto
Fernández fan de Legend hizo especial
hincapié en que la Unión Europea es el
principal inversor extranjero directo en
Argentina tiene un 40% de las
inversiones extranjeras directas en el
país y que la Unión Europea está
interesada en invertir aún más aquí en
el país y también en América Latina hizo
especial referencia a las energías
limpias al cobre
también mencionó el hidrógeno verde y
sobre todo el litio metal estratégico
que
tiene del que Argentina tiene grandes
reservas en el Noroeste del país
reservas que interesan a inversores de
Estados Unidos de Europa y de China por
igual También discutieron el tema del
acuerdo entre la Unión Europea y el
mercosur allí el presidente Alberto
Fernández refirió que Argentina necesita
revisar algunos puntos sobre todo lo que
tiene que ver con políticas
proteccionistas de Europa referentes a
los sectores como los agropecuarios que
pueden afectar a los productores
argentinos
que está interesada en que se pueda
llegar a un acuerdo para resolver las
diferencias antes de fines de este año
en Colombia los cuatro menores de edad
que fueron rescatados de la selva en el
departamento del guaviare se encuentran
en buen estado de salud según el más
reciente reporte del Ministerio de
defensa y del hospital Militar mientras
el terreno continúa la búsqueda de
Wilson el perro rescatista que ayudó en
las operaciones y que sigue desaparecido
Max Pérez Gallardo tiene la historia los
niños rescatados del guaviare con buena
salud después de estar más de un mes en
la selva Virgen del guaviare los cuatro
hermanos mucutuís se encontraban
exhaustos y con signos de desnutrición
visible sin embargo tras tres días
internados en el hospital Militar de
Bogotá el ministro de salud colombiano
confirma que los pequeños se encuentran
estables y con buena salud y quiero
darle un parto a todos los colombianos
de la buena salud que tienen hoy
nuestros niños y especialmente la forma
como ha sido tratado y atendido por
parte de esta gran institución los
equipos de rescate hicieron uso de
altavoces helicópteros con cámaras de
calor y grandes reflectores para
iluminar la noche en la espesa selva sin
embargo el protagonista del rescate fue
Wilson un perro rescatista que fue vital
para que los cuerpos de búsqueda dieran
con el paradero de los niños las huellas
de Wilson guiaron a los rescatistas
hacia los menores pero el perro ya no
estaba con los Hermanos la ubicación de
Wilson es desconocida aún pero el
ejército expresó que no pararán las
operaciones en la selva hasta
encontrarlo bueno la operación Esperanza
continúa
de acuerdo a los lineamientos del señor
presidente señor ministro de la defensa
nacional esta operación culmina Dios
mediante con la ayuda de él Hasta que
logremos recuperar al canino Wilson en
este momento tenemos en esta área de
operaciones
setenta comandos de la fuerzas militares
en la búsqueda y en la recuperación del
canino los niños fueron rescatados del
Amazonas colombiano el pasado 9 de junio
por un equipo de rescate conformado por
el ejército nacional y las comunidades
indígenas locales un hito histórico que
ha traído felicidad a los hogares en
Colombia y terminamos con una imagen que
llega desde Río de Janeiro o mejor
decenas de imágenes reflejadas a través
de espejos se trata de la exposición
digital mar de espejos que usa
tecnología para proyectar en pantallas
panorámicas diferentes maravillas del
mar los espejos están instalados en
nueve salas que miden en total 1300
metros cuadrados la experiencia estará
abierta al público desde el próximo
jueves en aquario el acuario Marino más
grande de América del Sur Y con estas
imágenes Nos despedimos sigan conectados
con France 24
[Música]